aujourd'hui on va faire un petit atelier
conserve
jouez vous proposer des conserve au
vinaigre parce que ça me semblait assez
simple mais on va voir quelques
techniques qui vont être je pense
intéressante et que vous pourrez
reproduire facilement pour julie c'est
une première habituellement elle et son
compagnon propose des ateliers dédiés au
savoir faire culinaire mais depuis le
confinement impossible d'accueillir des
stagiaires dans leur cuisine
il a donc fallu trouver un autre moyen
de poursuivre leurs activités
on a fait un test on a fait un taulier
en direct live le dimanche suivant on a
fait du pain pendant six heures ici et
eu 150 personnes qui ont suivi six
heures d'atelier en direct on était
totalement subjugué et aux familles mais
c'est super il ya une demande
de l'autre côté de l'écran ils sont une
centaine à suivre en direct cette
recette de conserve
connectés depuis les quatre coins de la
france et parfois même de beaucoup plus
loin lorsque vous demande si on peut
parler beaucoup aux changements que
l'une des pissenlits et la grèce
alors ça tu crois déjà sur le blog ouais
ça j'ai mis des petits articles sur le
sur le blog la semaine dernière et la
semaine passée une forme à pain brioche
conserves de légumes
julie et guillaume ont choisi de
partager des recettes du quotidien rien
de plus naturel pour ces militants du
fait maison
le confinement a été un coup de
projecteur sur une nécessité qui était
fondamentale avant qu'il sera encore
plus demain qui est de gagner en
autonomie par rapport à la grande
distribution et la production
industrielle nous persuader de ça mais
on veut le faire de façon joyeuse et
nous culpabiliser entre on n'est pas ici
pour jeter l'opprobre sur le fasse ou la
grande distribution juste on essaie
d'explorer un logement en attendant de
pouvoir à nouveau recevoir du public
le couple élabore ses futures recettes
et donc quelques jours un atelier sera
consacré à la cuisine végétarienne
de quoi varier les plaisirs pendant le
confinement